I'm here with retired uh Vice Marshal
Sean Bell advisor for Universal defense
and Security Solutions Sean great to be
with you again and uh doing something
slightly different today which is to
look at NATO then and now three decades
ago and today uh and the expansion there
ahead of President Biden's trip of
course to Poland this weekend to just
try and understand how Russia might
interpret it or really the spin let's
face it that Vladimir Putin might put on
it this is a snapshot of the mid-1990s a
couple of years after the Soviet Union
fell uh Sean and and talk us through the
sort of main points to note here well
first of all NATO was essentially a
defensive Alliance so an attack on one
is an attack on all and after all these
the defense of your nation is number one
priority for any country anywhere in the
world
um the very success of NATO at the time
was that yes a few more countries wanted
to join but I think the key Point here
is that big buffer between the East and
Edge of NATO and the western edge of
Russia there were 16 members then
including the US and Canada let's jump
now to today and clearly that buffer has
disappeared yes and I think you have to
overlay on this the fact that in the
late 90s Putin Rose to power as the
president as well so he's been sort of
presiding over a lot of this era 23
years in power at the end of the sort of
Soviet era of
um the Russian Federation as it were the
number of new States emerged they've
been used to a really difficult stagnant
economy and these new states were
looking for growth prosperity and
freedoms some of them looked East and
formed alliances with Russia some of
them look West and looked to the Warsaw
Pact the Baltic states and looked to the
European Union and NATO for for that
security prosperity and freedom and
always support to reiterate of course
it's a defensive organization and those
countries that joined in the
intermittent period sought to join as
opposed to to outright expansion from
the original members Sean give us some
specifics for example maybe what British
NATO troops might be doing in some of
these countries which countries uh in
and around this current War yeah so NATO
being defensive it doesn't mean you have
to wait until somebody's attacked before
you doing the thing so the Putin
invading Ukraine has heightened the
threat to Eastern the Eastern flank of
NATO so we've seen NATO bolstering an
Eastern flank with land forces Maritime
forces of the South and of course Air
Forces and the UK undoubted it's got
typhoons operating up in the Baltic
states uh and being they have a variety
of different basing options they can
choose which include in country or maybe
as far south as Cyprus interesting and
of course one of the factors that we've
been discussing is if Putin wants to
stop this expansion uh invading
countries doesn't doesn't help that and
we've seen big shift in opinion polls in
some of those countries like Finland and
Sweden as to whether they want to join
let's now dive in on Ukraine uh in
particular and just snapshot where we
stand at the moment and the good thing
tiny positive of all of this Sean is
that the red here hasn't expanded too
much in the last week or so no and I
think although the humanitarian crisis
continues I think
um Mario poll still see shows a
Bellwether of UK training resistance and
given the difficulties that Putin's
forces are evidently having trying to
take Mario poll it's pretty evident from
pewter perspective that Kiev will be
even more difficult and therefore
potentially a bridge too far I think the
positive thing as well we're seeing
though is not just the Ukrainian
military it's their civilian population
as well and they're not only defending
they're also fighting back there's
reports now certainly up towards Kiev of
some areas being retaken by the
Ukrainian forces so it's evident that
their Spirit has not been dampered but
has been bolstered by the events of the
last few days Sean Bob thanks so much
that's the latest on day 27.